welcome back to New rockstars I'm Anna
vanston and by the time I finish this
sentence eight more Mario trailers will
be out as you may know as I was filming
the last breakdown two new trailer
surfaced and if you don't know that it's
because you didn't watch the breakdown
till the end noted really though if you
missed my last two breakdowns go watch
them at least weren't huge releases like
the first two trailers which is why we
unfortunately couldn't find high quality
footage of either of them looking for
details in these gave me flashbacks to
when I was in denial that I needed
glasses and thought that everyone
couldn't see the faces of performers at
shows anyway let's jump into the
slightly blurry Easter eggs I was able
to find starting with the first trailer
it opens with Mario and Luigi venturing
around a sewer system in the human world
judging from the lack of color and
cartoonish style gray pipes ill they're
assumingly on a job but it looks like
they haven't explored this particular
area before as they look around in awe
I'm really hoping we're gonna get a
scene where Mario enters a room that
just has a one lone green pipe and
that's where it all begins but either
way it looks like we will be getting the
plot of them being on a job before
accidentally getting sucked around a
pipe and ending up in the other Universe
then we see them in that in between pipe
Dimension and we do indeed get that
losing grip moment I predicted in my
second breakdown before they're sucked
off into dip no no sorry can't use that
phrase before they're whisked away into
separate pipes Luigi going to the one
pipe surrounded by dark and foreboding
clouds rough luck we're introduced to a
new enemy from the game called a Bram
ball and then we're showing a red hot
air balloon flying towards Bowser's
airship hot air balloons aren't new to
the Mario games and although we haven't
seen this exact one before in the games
it's the same one that's in the Luigi
promotional poster where he's getting
chased that combined with the fact that
the next shot is Luigi captured being
led by ropes through Bowser's Castle by
a snippet and two shy guys and the four
red pixels in the hot air balloon that I
can make out from this blurry footage
that I'm assuming is a shy guy I would
say this is probably the shy guy
Snippets hot air balloon when my eyes
are glued to a computer screen they're
glued to my phone because I'm playing
rage Shadow Legends raid is what would
happen if you took a superhero movie
size budget and made a mobile game it's
awesome a braid has star power they've
released a legendary champion based off
MMA and pro wrestling Legend Ronda
Rousey Rhonda fights dragons and Ice
golems with her bare fists and her
backstory is pretty cool taking some
inspiration from her background in
Combat Sports Verona's true potential as
a fighter became obvious as she took on
four nights bare-handed she's the queen
of the arena and an awesome character
you definitely want to have in your
roster and you can get her first
for a new or long time player just by
logging into raid all you've got to do
is log on and play raid for seven days
between now and February 20th and
Rhonda's yours that's it if you use
promo code raid Rhonda you'll get a
bunch of helpful stuff like a three day
100 XP boost 500k silver and five full
energy refills the lapirana so she's at
the top per game if you're an Amazon
Prime member you can get even more
rewards if you haven't started playing
radio Now's the Time click the link in
the description or scan the QR code here
on the screen and you'll get unique
bonuses worth thirty dollars that's a
free epic Champion Aina 200k silver one
energy refill and one XP boost and one
ancient Shard so you can summon awesome
Champions as soon as you get in game
this bonus is available for new players
only and will be waiting for you in raid
right here next we get to see Bowser's
Throne which has a hint of his throne in
Super Mario Galaxy 2 but looks like it's
in the center of this giant version of
him sitting so he sits on a throne of
him sitting look closely and you can
also see that he already has acquired a
star which is floating above him then
Rush on Mario and Peach stepping through
a parted waterfall to get to a hidden
balcony the waterfall closes behind them
as the platform departs showing that one
of those classic Cool Secret waterfall
exits which I've been dying to get from
my Empire apartment but my landlord
ain't having it we see a new painting in
the background but if you thought the
paintings were blurry before try adding
720p footage to that there's water and
land and that's what I got so I can see
a more clear version but we can tell the
platform balcony they're standing on is
the same one from the obstacle course
scene which you can tell via the lamps
and goal pole base so when it takes off
they're more than likely headed to the
obstacle course and we then see more of
that obstacle course where Mario is
jumping from Bonsai Bill to Bonsai bill
now let's talk bullet Bills versus
Bonsai bills visible this is a bonsai
bill ever since the new Super Mario came
out in 2006 bullet bills only have arms
no mouths and Bonsai bills only have
mouths no arms prior to 2006 bullet
bills only had Mouse and roughly 20 of
the games Bonsai bills always had open
mouths ever since they were introduced
in Super Mario World in the last
breakdown we talked about how Bonsai
bills almost always fly in a straight
line once fired which is true however
Mario Odyssey was the first game to ever
break this tradition so they might
continue on that path moving forward
there are also cap on sale bills and
Bullseye Bond size which always hone in
on Mario but those are different and not
what these are now they'll more than
likely call them both the bills in the
movies and it's designed to appeal to
the mass audience but since they haven't
called them that yet in the trailers all
I can do is look at the information
we're given and face things off that
while the eyes look a little different
the size of them the open mouths and the
lack of arms most closely resemble
Bonsai bills in the current Canon Mario
universe so that's why I refer to them
as such but back to the training course
this shot shows Mario leaping from build
a bill with ease eventually punching the
crap out of a wooden Bowser giving us a
the Grasshoppers ready moment that
presumably ends the training course
portion of this movie on to the next
trailer Mario and Toad are walking
through the mushroomed area and I've
skipped past saying this before but the
white birds and yellow butterflies you
see flying around are from quite a few
of the games fun fact those white birds
are just named little birds and I love
that toad says that Mario's brother has
landed in the dark lands that's under
Bowser's control dark land is the final
world of Super Mario Brothers 3 and in
the game is where Bowser's main Castle
stands then we're shown toad town and it
kills me that I can't see the background
clearly because you know there's so much
stuff back there here's what I can make
out though first off the ground is the
same color as paper Mario's toad town
and the lamp posts are similar too there
are all sorts of stands and fruits that
are quite reminiscent of the ones in
Delfino square and Toad's Harbor and
Mario Kart and I wouldn't be surprised
if we see more of the fruits that were
prominent in Super Mario Sunshine
there's a fountain in the middle that
looks to me like three Chief Chiefs
facing in different directions looking
at the buildings there's a mushroom
building with what looks to be a giant
frying pan through it which we'll come
back to in a bit below that we have what
looks to be a cute toy version of a
mushroom attached to a building which
could maybe indicate that it's a toy
store there is a place called Toad's toy
store in Toad Harbor in Mario Kart 8. so
they do have toy stores in this universe
and on top of that there looks to be
either a satellite or maybe a
surveillance camera and it's hard to
tell in the background we see little
floating islands like in the promotional
poster that have a big Super Mario 3D
Land Vibe and then in the foreground we
can see that a passing toad is shocked
to see Mario telling us that humans
don't come by too often there's also
clearly a very shady deal happening over
here but talk about that in another shot
we get what looked to be little coin
ATMs with the treasure chest symbol from
Super Mario Bros 3 on it and the toad
licking on lollipop off to the side that
looks a lot like the Pop's taste tea
makes in Paper Mario thinking back to
the house with a giant frying pan
sticking out of it and we may be getting
an introduction to the chef in this
movie in the following shots we see
Builder toad first seen in Super Mario
maker and this other Blue Toad starring
at Mario who I like to imagine is that
same toad as before who's just following
Mario around and never ceasing to be
shook we then get a better sense of
their complex pipe transportation system
they used to get around town and I gotta
say I'm just as perplexed as Mario I can
see that the thumbs up light comes on
when the pipe is clear for use but I
definitely thought that that red leaf
sign pipe would have led to that red
leaf sign pipe although my next working
theory is that both of those pipes would
have led to the leaf sector if you will
I will solve this logic puzzle the final
little detail we see in this trailer is
that when Mario finally does make it to
Princess Peach's castle the pipey comes
out of is in the center of a golden
plate shaped like a star and there's
little star detailing in the balcony
railing which is just a lovely touch and
that's all the new Mario footage we have
so far I'm afraid to blank honestly but
what or who do y'all think is going to
be the next one to be introduced in the
trailer I'm so excited to find out in
the meantime you can follow me on
Twitter at it'sanavanston and follow And
subscribe to new rockstars at new
rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love now if you'll excuse
me I'll just take this pipe to get out
of here
crap
[Music]
thank you